[Musique]
j'avais un truc à vous dire la mémoire
déboires c'est déjà arrivé j'imagine de
faire une activité par exemple dans un
petit village
là vous dit rien j'appelle telle
personne mais vous continuez de piégut
large l'autre là je vous ramassez le
linge vous le ranger vous êtes par la
pièce où il ya le téléphone et quand
vous arrivez dans cette pièce vous dit
qu'est-ce que je file chez vous et
j'arrivais et là qu'est ce que vous
faites pour en fait leur beurre oui je
sais vous refaites le chemin inverse
physiquement vous répète le linge et
onirique j'appelle des machins et vous
êtes contents vous êtes et vous ai perdu
du temps j'ai fait l'expérience avec
vous je vais vous demander de faire
exactement comme moi à faire une petite
expérience de mémoire dans des cas nous
pratiquons des mairies bratus du
combattant qui croient qu assez libre a
amené les bras levé les bras
david huchet tout autre raté du raïs y
est pas ça c'est dangereux
les pouces vers le bas
là vous allez vous rendre compte que
plus vous approcher des mafieux vous
approcher les vaincus vous approcher des
mains puis se touche c'est normal un peu
plus compliqué je vais vous demander de
croiser les bras un peu plus haut de
plus en plus compliqué je vais vous
demander de croiser les doigts france m
c'est très important sous de monsieur
compact et deux jours entre vos doigts
ses traits à comprendre mirepoix
quelques jours on y va
j'ai trouvé les cousins sens des
aiguilles d'une montre l'indicateur
tourner tourner très vite et on a un
petit effort musculaire vous allez
regarder les poussent vers le haut
vous êtes bloqué déjà l'attention sur
internet mais ça va forcément impacter
notre mémoire
la belle façon de leur belle je suis un
humaniste un mélodiste
c'est un spécialiste des stratégies de
mémorisation je suis minimaliste et
magicien il utilise en fait
historiquement je suis d'abord maritime
et au début des années 2000 j'ai fait un
lien entre le entre l'illusion et la
mémoire
figurez vous que les magiciens pour vous
y missionné ils vont s'amuser avec votre
mémoire de travail d'y revenir dans sa
lettre je vais juste pour un comptable
contexte comment j'en suis venu à matéri
cian sable l'eau rapidement
en fait moi en tant que magicien j'ai
commencé à peu près en 1989
je me suis rapidement intéressé à ce
qu'on appelle le closer voici vous
connaissez le close up si l'art et la
manière de faire des petits tours de
magie en interactivité direct avec les
gens très près et donc j'étais
régulièrement engagés pour animer des
cocktails et en 1995 je te poser de
questions comment est ce que je pourrais
avoir un bon petit spectacle en
apparence et lâche m'intéresse à une
discipline les illusionnistes c'est le
mentalisme passagers données de chacun
d'entre vous ici ou en tout cas la
plupart vous avez déjà entendu parler de
l'antenne le mentalisme ce n'est que là
un de faire croire qu'on est capable de
lire dans les pensées de faire des
prédictions ya toujours un truc
avez vous vu les magiciens sont d'abord
de gens disent escaut dans cette
discipline qu'est le mentalisme il y
avait ce phénomène en tout cas cette cet
art de prévoir prodigieuse les mémoires
j'ai trouvé ça sympa j'ai commencé à
prendre de petits trucs et finalement
qu'est ce qui m'intéressait c'était
d'apporter une petite plus-value avant
l'intervention par exemple retenir les
prénoms des gens pendant que je faisais
un petit tour de cartes
je trouve ça assez fun si vous êtes
passés parmi les jambes agetic à tout ce
qu'un parti gauche qui s'appelait par
leur prénom je les appliquer il ya la
fin de l'intervention avec eux je leur
disais au revoir en mai on alors dire au
revoir par leur prénom
et je passe comme ça c'est bon et puis à
force de faire ça j'étais plus à simon
asseoir 995 je décide il tant que coo de
dire au revoir à toutes les personnes
présentes en cocktail mieux qu'ils sont
420 personnes hier évidemment moins des
bars si vous voulez jouer un sac de
noeuds petite cerise
je vais bientôt ses bases c'est sympa
donc je fais mon intervention je prends
les mouvements dézinguer d'autres chez
mon tour de cartes est arrivé à la fin
donc de l'intervention vous devez pas
deux heures mais je m'arrête je termine
je monte sur scène
n'envoyez pas et je commence à dire au
revoir à tout le monde
j'avais particulier de pression
particulière
on va bien on voit bien engagée pour
faire des tours de magie donc ça
marchait tant mieux ça marchait pas
tendre
là je pense à dire envoie à tous par
leur prénom voici vous imaginez vous
êtes à peu près une centaine
c'est comme si je puis dire au revoir
chacun à part en live et un grand
silence dans la salle
ce que je pensais être la cerise sur
gâteau et depuis le plus longtemps
je repars à peu étonné parce que dans la
tête si vous voulez moi il morizet des
prénoms sa part s est beaucoup plus
simple que de faire un tour de magie un
tour de magie
beaucoup de groupes étant il faut faire
les choses aussi penser il faut pas dire
ce qu'on fait faut pas faire ce qu'on
dit et là quelques temps plus tard il ya
une personne qui était présent de ce
cocktail qui m'appelle qui dit comme ça
bonjour vous avez l'autre jour cocktail
vache un drame on a bien vu votre
intervention et on aimerait vous engager
on discute on discute et à la fin
d'intervention ces personnes dévouées au
foot tous des prénoms choisis avait rien
à faire des tours de magie
ce qui vous laisse le gars qui ont
atteint des prix et un jour on lui
demande d'expliquer comment je faisais
je vais vous expliquer dans un instant
je vais vous dire exactement comment
vous fait mais avant ça j'aimerais pour
vous raconter un peu l'histoire ça du
sort de l'arc la mémoire d'où ça vient
dans l'antiquité dans la mythologie
grecque
yann tsx appels médiévaux dean né
musique la dance music son rôle c'est de
raconter des histoires aux autres dieux
et il se trouve qu'un soir alors qu'elle
racontait des histoires se soumet le
dieu des dieux
il semblerait que ça finisse police je
suis même été quelque chose
loyer bas ne pas dire pas ce qui se
passe en israël et de cette union
furtive naissent des neuf plus de deux
buts d'écart et de là on désigne des
voisines comme étant la ds la mémoire
est d'ailleurs tous les termes to de
mémoire viennent de mener moss tie break
1 les nonistes mnémotechnique née
monique tout ça s'avère donc de niveau c
est dans l'antiquité
autrefois si les orateurs qui des
personnes qui avaient l'habitude de
prendre la parole en public
toutes ces personnes avaient déjà à leur
disposition des tablettes c'est en
voyant marin samedi que nous et on
décide des sites comprendre comment
fonctionne cette mémoire qu'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire on essaie de trouver de
percer le
créé depuis musique qui compte au cden
d'une bonne deux mois était légale de
mes voisines ont cherché à percer le
secret d'une ps à pouvoir tient et
caisse pour comprendre sur l'époque
l'ape à force de recherches de remarques
on se rend compte de deux choses
principales la première chose on se rend
compte que lorsqu'on est capable de
faire des associations et nous nous
associons divine et on retrouve mieux
les informations sont absolument
la deuxième chose qu'on remarque c'est
que lorsqu'on fait pas trop son coeur
lorsqu'on fait pas du tout peur et bien
pareil on retrouve une information on la
retient mieux à cette époque on l'avait
déjà compris le wall trade point
d'information associés les idées et le
rôle de la motivation la motivation
l'intérêt qu'a battre son coeur l époque
on croit même que la mémoire je suis
donc en 10 sec des êtres humains
bob évidemment à la recherche de l'année
voit dans le coeur
on ne trouve pas a bondi déjà resté
cette expression très commune que vous
connaissez tous et apprendre par coeur
historiquement apprendre par coeur c'est
avec cette singulière à prendre avec
passion avec internet et ça c'est
fondamental
ça change absolument tout j'ai encore
des tas de personnes qui est me dis stop
ça arrange et des problèmes pour gêner
nom et prénom et pourtant si personnel
lorsque vous les mettez face une
personne guyane coup de foudre tout net
nous ils retiendront le prénom nos
téléphones adresses d'avancer leur
assiette
la motivation est fondamentale donc
c'est ce qu'on avait compris nous à
cette époque là évidemment les
recherches ont continué dans des banques
est de plus en plus de choses par par la
mémoire par exemple celui il ya
quasiment autant de formes de mémoire
que de nature d'information quand on se
plaint de sa mémoire en général je
plaint d'une forte voix et pas de la
mémoire
les recherches continuent et on découvre
une sorte de mémoire qu'on appelle la
mémoire de travail mené par le travail
ses mémoires qui sert à travailler
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle la mémoire
me travaille son rôle si vous voulez
c'est de capter l'environnement au
présent et d'interagir que ça vous
permettent de vivre le présent sans y
penser
le problème c'est que cette mémoire là
est la limite
au bout de cinq sites d'information elle
commence inception est toujours jeu
finalement c'est de contrôler la base
d'informations la formation qui vous
arrive la comparer avec tout ce que vous
connaissez par coeur et d'interagir avec
l'environnement par exemple quand vous
êtes en voiture produise et que vous
arrivez à un feu rouge il est en train
de vous demander auquel s est lui en
temps réel vous reconnaissez cette lueur
rouge comme étant un danger et vous
ferez des tanks en temps réel vous
reconnaissez le feu rouge vous le
comparez les sept joueurs avec ce que
vous savez parker c'est à dire danger et
vous réalisez en tant qu elle le blog ce
que si à trop d'informations qui
arrivent bien là vous pouvez vraiment
être en danger
c'est pour ça que vous reprendre une
pâte et l'estonie ne pas faire trop de
choses à la fois pour mobiliser eux pour
s'abriter la mémoire de travail la
mémoire plus court je vais vous poser
cette bouteille d'eau n'est pas vous
avez donc neymar de travail qui tapait
le boulot ici si à trop d'informations
qui arrivent en général plus de 5 600
dit que on dit que la limite de la
mémoire de travail d'environ 7 plus ou
moins 2 ça dépend de la nature de la
formation
plus l'information et compliquent et
plus est les gourous si vous voulez des
plus c'est difficile à faire passer dans
le camp le boulot au bout de quelques
informations seulement il ya un espèce
de bouchons qui se forment ici et donc
ça empêche la formation
la seule solution que vous ayez vraiment
c'est de contrôler la masse
d'informations et sa vitesse donc pas
trop d'informations pour passer dans le
goulot maintenant si cette information
là vous n'en faites rien si vous ne la
traite et inscrivez compris les anciens
et là elle risque d'être rejeté en tout
cas d'être juger de leur pertinence dans
ce que vous devez faire c'est utiliser
l'information sans faire quelque chose
pour la ramener un peu plus loin qu'ils
le voient plutôt moyen terme si vous
voulez la radiation du très long terme
il faut utiliser dans le temps c'est à
cette condition que votre souvenir sera
plus ou moins ternes
sinon l'information risque de l'umq
d'être oubliés de disparaître donc trois
formations trop vite et aussi sur la
tête des interférences si au moment où
vous êtes en train de prendre
l'information
vous avez quelqu'un qui vous dérange
quelque chose qui vous dérange il a
cette information finalement elle ne
sera pas traitée elle reste il avant de
partir c'est ce qui se passe notamment
cantons qui sont là pour penser
quelqu'un et au final on laisse passer
un petit peu de temps pour aller en
cours proposés ce niveau et elisa donc
vous devez vraiment faire attention à
cela contrôler la masse et la vitesse
l'information
allez-vous certains pensent peut-être
que l'âge c'est que cette mémoire du
mans est moins performante à la télé on
a bien concurrence des personnes âgées
de plus de 40 ans contredit
les personnes de plus de 70 ans pour
savoir si vous suiviez et des jeux de 20
ans on leur a demandé comme ça de
retenir une poésie en 15 minutes au bout
de 15 minutes
qu'est ce qu'on remarque au revoir tout
simplement que les plus jeunes bat les
jeunes de plus de 16 ans visant il a les
personnes âgées au civil voilà c'est
comme ça or on perd des neurones avec
l'âge la scientifique 10 la tendance
n'était pas aussi simple que ça on va
refaire l'expérience on va vous redonner
une poésie et vous allez le prendre le
temps qu'il faut pour tenter de la
réduire
qu'est ce qu'on remarque on remarque
effectivement les plus âgés mettre deux
trois voire quatre fois plus de temps
pour recréer cette poésie
mais lorsqu'on les questionne lorsqu'on
les interroge elles sont capables de
retrouver la poésie quand même titre que
les plus jeunes on sait pas forcément
des sondages c'est une question s'il
voulait au départ du pratique c'est
pratique justement de maîtriser cette
les mardis de travail dans des contextes
différents
car lorsque vous êtes étudiant lorsque
vous êtes avait encore musclé au collège
à l'étude quand vous avez l'habitude de
varier des sources apprentissage dont
vous maîtrisez mieux cette sorte de
mémoire de travail pour on va dire à
prendre reste plusieurs actes lorsqu'on
doit dire plus adultes en général on va
plutôt pour traire se spécialiser à la
gloire du père spécialisés et pour la
plus l'habitude de sortir de cette zone
de confort donc à penser que ce que vous
voulez si vous avez le sentiment que
votre mémoire est moins performant
qu'avant tout simplement et bien c'est
sorti le plus souvent de votre zone de
confort de varier vos sources intérêt à
des choses un peu différentes de ceux ci
dans le fonctionnement un peu revenu au
prénom les sens étaient peu présents que
j'avais à traiter lors de cette soirée
que j'ai réitéré la bande en temps pour
vivre tout simplement je respecte cette
année noire de travail au jeu seul bout
de 4-5 informations ça va devenir
probité donc on travaille à voir tous
les bouts des ministres c'est de
maîtriser cette mémoire de travail
c'est donc ne pas la sous estimer il est
pas je vais complètement contrôlé la
vitesse et la base d'informations c'est
quand je vais passer dans un petit
j'ai évité de prendre de 2,34 et non 4 5
ans maximum à chaque fois qu'on me donne
un créneau je prends le petit temps
nécessaire ces traits d'une petite
seconde pour faire une association
d'idées avec une personne que je connais
le grand danger si vous voulez lorsqu'on
est dans des soirées ça vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vu c'est d'arriver la
maison que peut-être aujourd'hui mais
sans mouvement 72 des jardins d'un
prénom est au bout du cinquième des
entraînements publics d hydro s'appelle
cette personne est ce que vous pensez
que parce que cette personne nous a
donné son prénom
vous auriez dû la retire donc ça marche
pas comme ça qu au contraire se
présenter bonjour madame
avant de passer à la seconde personne
fait le travail petit travail la prime
que tout ce monde d'utiliser le prénom
qu'on vous donne de l'associer à
quelqu'un vous connaisez ou juste de le
répéter avant de passer à la sauver et
au bout de la quatrième personne arrêtée
vous est réactivée rapidement les quatre
ou cinq francs veux juste que ça en
faisant ça vous allez passer du coup
l'eau vers le vide au début c'est pas
plus aux équipes ça évidemment c'est par
la pratique avant car son prénom alors
débarque dès que vous fassiez avec 25
systèmes différents
mettez ces sabots grève ça fonctionne si
vous ne faites pas ça vous serez piégé
par cette peur de travail et les
mutations que tout à l'heure avec les
mains vous avez dirigé et là vous aurez
l'impression que c'est du mark ronson
moyens qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout à
leurs victimes
je vous explique ont travaillé à droite
opposition c'est le saturer votre
mémoire de travail pour vous abonner à
publier le truc que j'étais saoul bouzou
qui se cherche nullement de faire
exactement que voir tendez les bras
cassés libre a ramené les bras levé les
bras à celle du type blague
la photo c'est maintenant certain henry
on venait ici faites pas ça quand je
vois des gens faire ça je sais qu'ils
sont déjà cette semaine montrent encore
et ça ça me donne une super indications
ça veut dire que cette personne là ces
personnes là sans doute et à mo'nique et
des grandes chances qu'il ya 17 mois
donc cette passe alors décidé pouces
vers le bas
plus on approche que la proche qu'on
approche plus elle se touche deuxième
blague 3d libre a osé les doigts et
c'est là que le truc a lieu à ce qu'on
voit là bas je mise sur un sur un truc
c'est que diviser votre attention
forcément vous avez une position qui
n'est pas tout à fait naturel et qu'est
ce que je fais je regarde les uns les
autres et je prends une personne comme
ça au hasard à nouveau l'attention il
faut pas qu'ils y est toujours entre vos
doigts qui décroise laura monitoring et
je pars du principe qu'il ya l'espèce si
vous voulez du souvenir collectif qui va
se passer
à l'époque souvent par l'enseignant
prenez à partir des lèvres jambes
attention ne pas faire de foot as une bo
chacun d'entre vous souhaitez atteindre
parce que j'étais une faute là sans
doute que dans cette salle de leurs
congés rouge qui était le monsieur de
dia temps donc vous n'êtes pas forcément
fait attention à voir je suis revenue
sous vos yeux comme ceux-ci d'accord à
ce moment là je fais mon illusion vous
prenez ce qui ce passe
je vais donc continuer à saturer votre
mémoire de travail en crise en créant ce
qu'on appelle une parenthèse pour ne pas
en tête les scientifiques appellent ça
une interférence et 3
je veux faire parents des suppliciés
bissonnet la parenthèse oublie c'est
quand je vous demande de tourner les
pouces dans le sens des aiguilles d'une
montre
ça sert à rien mais ça fait passer un
tout petit peu de temps et lorsque je me
crée une illusion
forcément vous voulez tenter votre
chance d'un goûter notre marche pas et
l'envié de l'autre côté
ça va vous énervez couple et si vous
qualifiez les conditions de l'oubli
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]